brother from another is michael smith
whose show uh follows our with michael
holly every day right here on nbc sports
on peacock back here on our show how are
you sir
good just concerned why y'all eating
pumpkin pie
exactly mike um
it's also 9 22 a.m pacific time he's
challenging him to do it
that's
that's fact come on now these are the
facts that he spits that's part of the
reason why we have you on michael's you
spit facts
that you're not a hot taker you're
reasonable you're smart you know i think
so you've got taste you've got style you
know you you you dovetail with our
program it's basically occupies for
people who
don't
know how to make or
can't find a sweet potato pie and
they're settling for pumpkin pie because
it's you know
here's what i said michael michael i i
once upon a time covered a rodeo in
redding california okay right all right
and i'm a new york jew i don't know what
the hell was going on you know uh i
actually was interviewing the uh the
all-around cowboy time murray and it was
that i had no idea what he looked like i
went in there and i'm like can you point
out ty murray which at the time would
have been similar to walking in the
united center and saying can you point
out michael jordan like they gave me
cross-side looks the reason why i bring
this all up is i thought to myself as
i'm watching all of these
uh uh competitions play out i'm like who
thought of this it was just probably
somebody was bored and drunk on the
range
and to me that's the way i think pumpkin
pie was created somebody was somebody
was in a patch bored drunk and it's like
let's make a pie out of it like we got
nothing but pumpkins let's just make the
best of this situation perfect
yeah you know what i'm saying i can see
that it's kind of it's kind of like i've
you know been since last night i've been
trying to figure out
like because just we take it for granted
because we all just i mean i think i did
it instinctively i don't think anybody
had to tell me to do this
but it was the first person who decided
man you know what like i should do with
these oreos is dunking in milk
yeah like who was the first to do that
neck and they're putting it the word
spread a genius that's whoever that
person was maybe then i was trying to
think after giannis you know discovered
fire last night i'm just like well
what's the last thing that
what's the last thing that just kind of
blew my mind was the last game changer
so for somebody once upon a time pumpkin
pie must have been a game changer it was
oh we could make a pie out of this for
giannis duncan oreo's a game changer i'm
trying to think of the last thing that
just like blew my mind like that they
just like oh man that's like cam newton
put me on
two uh lucky charms and cinnamon toast
crunch mixed
yeah incredible
wow
that is that's probably amazing is that
what the cereal he was referring to
about eating that cereal a week before
hopefully is that the cereal he's
referring to i'm guessing it is because
once you go lucky charms and cinnamon
toast crunch you do not go back
um the other thing that came to mind for
me was hennessey and lemonade i don't
know how many uh hennessey
are here but hennessy and lemonade go
all right i'm gonna write all these down
it's really a long weekend for me i
guess i don't know how do i make the
segue from this conversation to lebron
punching somebody in the face how do i
do that i don't know other than just
walk through the door
anything is possible so nfc has led to
quite a few people getting punched in
the face penny will lead to a scratch so
we are at the holiday season so there's
pumpkin pie and there's fights
the spice that's the spice that's the
spice uh michael smith here on the rich
eisen show so what do you make of lebron
getting one game fewer than the guy he
punched what do you think about it i
didn't like it
i didn't like it and okay did isaiah
stewart
uh
reacts uh more dramatically
than we've typically seen from somebody
getting hit in the face sure
but far be it for me to tell somebody
how they should behave after getting hit
in the face
and you know being blinded by their own
blood
so
again and let's focus on
the root word he overreacted as in there
was something that
precipitated his reaction which was
getting hit in the face
so for me
i just felt like
they should have gotten equal suspension
like i guess i just don't understand
what the well i get what the second game
is for from stewart but what's the first
game for you understand i'm saying like
give him one if you think that he calls
an unnecessary uh scene but you don't
give him two
when he never hit anybody in the face to
begin with well i guess if you're
looking at the penalty in terms of uh
i guess something to uh teach a lesson
in a way right right a deterrent thank
you sir uh that's the word i was looking
for if you're looking for it as a
deterrent
um that's the extra game because you
don't want
um people the size of nba players sure
spilling in any way shape or form in a
direction of a fan that's sitting right
there on the floor because remember he
got hit in the face so he would have got
hit in the face and gotten suspended for
a game for how he reacted getting in the
face
and everybody square even stephen
but to give him two
acted as to me says that what he did was
more egregious than what lebron did now
lebron tried to apologize immediately he
sought out his phone number i'm not here
to judge lebron's intent but that looked
like a closed fist to me
and
you know if lebron's gonna be suspended
for what started the incident
it just felt like um
it just felt like stewart shouldn't have
gotten two
you know i would have i would have been
okay with stuart getting one
but again
he got hit in the face and if he you
know
lost his mind as a result
i mean okay
get hit in the face and see how you
would react i would love to know what
part of the rule book says this is how
you're supposed to conduct yourself
where does this i know what it says in
the bible i don't know where it says
turn the other cheek in the rule book um
but
you know lebron lebron will be back uh
and
they'll both be back for this next
pistons game anthony davis had an
interesting point
about our guys get hit in the face all
the time yeah but he didn't require nine
stitches to close one of them ever right
and that didn't look like that didn't
look like pure traditional incidental
contact that looked excessive on the
part of lebron i mean lebron shouldn't
be throwing an elbow on like that i mean
he's got it i think he i think it was
more of a closed fist it looks like an
elbow from one angle but from the top
angle it's like a backhand closed fist
well either way
he's got to know you know that something
like that could could seriously injure
whoever is in his vicinity and that's
why that's why he suspended one game
four because that was that was really
reckless on his part exactly um so what
what do you make of the sense though
that uh stewart's reaction
speaks to a lack of respect for
lebron league wide
from the youngsters what do you think of
that concept that was forwarded in a way
by stephen a
michael smith what do you think of that
one
oh man it's thanksgiving let me be nice
so wait what what what what happened
okay
well no this speaks to a lack of respect
yes that that that players
got hit in the face and it went crazy
right but that that if jordan had ever
thrown that that elbow somebody wouldn't
want to go fight mike but lebron is a
different
story to the young kids in the nba right
now as compared to a previous generation
that was the uh
i'm getting that just correct chance
right isn't that right that's
essentially uh yeah essentially
i'll just put it this way your man
reached way up to pull that one out wow
i don't i don't i i don't get that
somebody got punched in the face
and i don't care who it was
like and first of all it's not about
lebron it's about isaiah stewart like
look into isaiah stewart's background
and isaiah stewart
by all accounts is one of those dudes
that you know you don't want to cross
you know i'm not saying he's charles
oakley but i mean isaiah stewart
got hit and and injured in a way
that would set anybody off i don't think
lebron i don't think anybody that gets
hit in the face in that moment is
thinking
man
this guy's one of the greatest players
ever
uh i probably shouldn't mess with him
all you're thinking about is i just got
hit in the face
and unless you know that that person is
gonna do any more damage to you you're
going after them so somebody's
reputation as a tough guy and that
moment doesn't matter
you know like
michael jordan i don't know that michael
jordan was ever considered some
incredible fighter who was it that he
pushed open-handed uh that time that's
you know but michael jordan is famous
for punching steve kerr in practice i
don't know if that makes michael jordan
a fighter per se well just not afraid of
him is essentially the sense but you
know yeah but i mean okay like who's
afraid of anybody in the nba if that's
what we're talking about like this this
was one incident this doesn't speak to
some
with all the respect rich could i please
like not have to entertain that no
problem the problem
let me move on then that michael smith
michael smith reporting that uh the
president not the only one to have a
colonoscopy this week
you touched the nerve there no i did i i
love it
we'll talk about that offline
no worries michael smith here on the
rich eisen show so um let's move on to
the nfl
why do you think baker mayfield gets as
much crap as he gets
oh that's loaded how about that why do
you think he gets as much crap
uh as as a as maybe anyone else in the
nfl like literally it was two weeks ago
that he boat raced
the bengals it's obvious that he's not
completely healthy and that he doesn't
have any protection up front odell's dad
is the one who's zapruder filming all
22. you know
and and and baker gets all the the crap
and very little of any credit
that other quarterbacks might get for
their moxie or what have you what do you
think that is
i'm more fascinated by the premise and
by the uh
by
by your take on it because it's it
sounds like it's unfair in your mind and
i guess i'm trying to figure out what
well here's the crap is unfair okay the
aspect inconsistent he is definitely he
is inconsistent yep he definitely is um
but he does perform well enough for this
team last year
and that the reason why they're six and
five is not his fault the defense was
garbage the first month of the season
you know he was the one who put up all
those points in kansas city and they
couldn't
stop kansas city despite having the lead
late i mean we could parse this thing
out completely
okay but
yeah
it feels like you're giving him and this
is typical the quarterbacks
feels like you're i don't know if you're
trying to like balance it out here
but if you're saying that he gets
if you're saying sorry i got somebody
actually calling me on my house phone
right now so sorry about the beats
that's steven a
i seriously doubt it um if if if you're
saying that somebody gets um
that he's getting too much blame
i feel like you're giving him too much
credit
like i think they play around baker
mayfield more than anything i think that
running game and that defense when it is
playing
is protecting baker mayfield does he
have some ability yeah does he have
flashes yeah
but i haven't seen somebody
who has
been the
franchise savior that a number one
overall pick he beat the crap out of the
steelers last year michael in a playoff
game when was the last time the browns
could say something like that he went
ahead and cincinnati relative to the
history recent history of brown's
quarterback yes or playoff utilities
sure definitely give him a cookie or a
pumpkin pie if you prefer but the
steelers at that point
were like completely falling apart and
ben roethlisberger had one of the
sloppiest most prolific stat lines in
nfl history you know what i mean still
threw that game away early but yeah sure
he gets credit for that i'm not saying
he's not a
above average starting quarterback or
the potential to be that right but i i
don't i don't think that i got i'm going
back to the premise which i'm rejecting
i don't think the criticism that he's
gotten has been unfair have there been
some circumstances around him that have
made his life
more difficult sure but therein lies a
difference between great quarterbacks
and okay quarterbacks as you know is the
ones that for the most part can overcome
some of those issues whereas baker
strikes me as a guy that needs
everything to be perfect around him they
boot him at home michael
they boot him in his home stadium
you know coming again just because they
struggled to beat
the detroit lions at home you know uh
without a considerable amount of their
pieces that's what i'm saying is that i
think i don't know another quarterback
that does that for a six and five team
coming off of a of a playoff season in
which also
um you know
he he he's come up with some big wins
that's that's what i'm saying who else
do you think he deserves a little bit of
a break a little bit of benefit of the
doubt well i mean i guess so yeah that's
what i'm saying that's what i've been
saying all all year long and you're
saying it's as many commercials baker
mayfield as then i've always struggled
to buy him
um
but maybe maybe there's another level
for him to go to i think he's okay
i think he's okay maybe the problem is
that's is that he's okay and that we're
your number one overall pick okay and
then in every commercial
uh on and you've got
all this different uh hype and hoopla
around you
maybe the expectation unfairly so
is that he's supposed to be more than
what he is
um
he has been beat up he is a tough kid
he's playing through it
um
but i what i'm really hearing though i
can psychoanalyze you for a second sure
i'm hearing a guy that just knows what
it's like to not have a quarterback and
see somebody that you think is
mistreating theirs
yes especially
hey man here's my point is like you know
ride your the horse that you're with
when the the horse that you're with has
the ability to win a playoff game for
you because you you might you know
regret having to go back into the draft
to find your guy and then that guy gets
hurt and then you trade
then then you trade then you trade
actual draft you trade actual draft
capital for somebody who would never
start for anybody else in the nfl
barring a huge car wreck um and he's an
unvaccinated quarterback who then is now
useless to you a week after you start
him because he's a close contact of a
guy who actually has it so so that's
what i'm saying like that's my current
situation as you've got you've now led
me to like would the browns prefer that
you know and i understand the concept of
why would i settle for mediocre play
when i hack can get better
yeah you can get better actually in the
next six weeks with this guy is what i'm
saying the jets can't with the guys
i feel your pain on that bruh and and i
last time i talked to you i think
i might if i recall correctly it's been
a couple weeks i think i got kind of
excited about mike white yeah
i was telling you like yo man this is a
it's a first world problem this ain't a
problem like you actually might have a
they have two quarterbacks
yeah the jets started yeah michael the
jets started building him a statue
outside of metlife but it looks like the
venus de milo now they can't complete it
with arms and a head they just stopped
it's over mike white's statue is just
like half a body that's basically what
it is out there and that's again that's
my point that's my point do you want to
go back there and i understand that
might be a false choice for some
but that's the reality once you do go
down that road of what the plan b is and
why you're booing the guy when you have
no idea what he's actually going through
to get out there that's all i'm saying
and i feel like i'm very considerate of
you i got nothing personal against baker
i hope he works out cleveland deserves
it but i do what i love most about that
take is
you know you got to uh appreciate what
you have yes
the other half doesn't even have
mediocrity that is also a sign of our
times too michael you know like live in
the moment carpe diem appreciate what
you have while you have it uh i feel
like i've pissed you off with choices of
of asking you questions no no no no no
no no
no rich okay oh no never never it just
was just
i'm sorry no
no it's not your baggage
it's me
i didn't know i was triggering i really
had no idea why would you why would you
i mean it's my job
it's my job because i get punched in the
face
accept it and move on and not run around
like a madman michael smith everybody
john michael he did not all right leave
the conversation in a timely fashion
right
he just dropped it he went out the
tunnel and he tried to certainly just
circle back
that's exactly what just happened
who's on your show later today sir who
do you got um what do you got we got
well you know what i'm going to see your
jk simmons
and
uh
i won't say raise you but match you with
uh glenn turman
uh speaking of rodeo okay
okay performer okay very good uh and
then our regular visits from uh vincent
goodwill and uh jason johnson so we're
gonna chop it up talk about uh
a number of things some of the things
we've just covered with the exception of
that uh hot take about
why well michael
ask ask uh your guest about my theory
about how certain competitions and rodeo
were created is it based on just being
bored and drunk back in the range back
in the day and just saying you know
here's this rope i'm going to throw it
around this animal and see what can
happen we'll do before i let you go yes
sir if i if i may are you up against the
car not at all
okay before i let you go if i may um
because you know
i have an ohio state buckeye
i don't have a dog in this fight
but i want to be on your side thank you
but i don't feel good about it
can you tell me why michigan is going to
knock off ohio state i can't say that
with any certainty there is a road map
however as opposed to previous years the
road map is they've got two spectacular
pass rushers coming from either end of
the line
they also have a spectacular running
back and hassan haskins who will make
the world of some lucky team that
decides to choose him in the first round
of next year's draft he is that good and
they've got a quarterback who doesn't
make mistakes and they just got to put
up
they got to put up sevens instead of
threes and they gotta have takeaways
instead of you know giveaways and don't
let the ball get thrown over their heads
you know what and honestly that's and
that's that's about it you know and then
i'll just say this in terms of the um
the good versus evil here
aspect of it and i understand that i'm
treading into very very very uh uh dark
waters here
um
with my take here but do you want ohio
state to go again do you really want
them going again do you really want them
going to the big ten championship game
again you really want them in the
national championship
round of four again i mean let's get a
little variety out there you know what i
mean like let's see what jim harbaugh
can actually do
in all of that don't you think that that
would be a little bit more interesting
i'm just appealing to your sense of a
story of a of a storyline um you know
i'm sure you're just as much of a
of a storyline aficionado as i am um
exactly root for storylines you don't
think it's a better storyline to see
michigan go and see what happens with
harbaugh and then ohio state again like
what do you think
i don't have the emotional investment in
jim harbaugh that i did when he was in
and leaving san francisco and first
going to michigan yeah but either you
love him or you hate him there's there's
there's no there's no gray really are
you true i'm indifferent now it's been
too long and and too many disappointing
seasons that's exactly right that he
hasn't been there so getting him back
there he makes it more interesting jim's
more interesting the best teams make it
interesting i mean i want to root for
michigan because i just don't want to be
on the same side of michael holly and i
like you
you know quiet as kept don't tell him i
refer you to michael thank you um so i
just want to root for michigan for those
patrolling purposes more than anything
but ohio state's the better team and
honestly i just want to see the best
teams not only that i don't want to see
expansion not to get off on a whole
other topic but like this season i'm
kind of like rethinking my whole stance
on college football well just you know i
mean just this now you've opened a whole
can here and when we are kind of getting
close to being up against it sorry but
no but the whole idea again that you've
just mentioned
that ohio st alabama's dropped below
ohio state in the rankings and we're
arguing about you know what's up with
that and ohio state you know alabama
hasn't played a good enough defense over
the last two three weeks or whatever
whoever the hell's in charge of that
committee said on espn last night and
people arguing about it's like we
shouldn't argue about it ohio state and
alabama should make it
in this championship round in a round of
eight and a round of 12. let's get i
know it takes a little bit of the edge
off a game like this weekend but it
still means a ton of stuff certainly if
it means that you get to stay at home
instead of on the road for the first
round of the playoffs like put a home
field advantage on it here i'll make it
quick i think do you want a tournament
or do you want a championship i want a
tournament that's what i want i don't
want a tournament i don't think there
are 12 teams that are championship
worthy teams and if they already approve
it in a regular season let's talk about
this next week how does that sound all
right
and and you'll know that in advance so
you'll know that in advance so i don't
piss you off and but you didn't piss me
off
you
you okay i want you guys to like dig
deeper into this i just want you to know
i just want you to my my hand was open
it wasn't closed when i asked that
question okay and my elbow was better
and you have my phone number if you want
to apologize all right very good michael
smith everybody michael all right
brother from another after us on nbc
sports on peacock at 3 eastern time hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here